here's the thing you know I know people
are gonna make fun of this and think
that this isn't a serious matter
I think we have to talk to her and I
think I have to talk about it and we
have to let people know that this
actually this is serious and it can ruin
your life
tick tock is a social media sensation
one of the hottest apps for videos of
dance challenges with social media Tech
Talk have taken the world by storm and
just to detail is huge it's the fastest
growing social media app in the world
you haven't heard of the tick tock nap
your children probably have they might
eat eternity news to grow the business
model is being questioned and tested at
a scale not seen before there's another
side of the app that's less fun than in
it's less creative and less fun
oh so you're gonna add a couple more
lights cuz I feel like this is really
dark like on why is this horizontal this
camera yeah right what do you mean what
was it I mean if we're doing a tick-tock
like it's not the right way Jenna I need
your help with something I got this
whole thing of toilet paper
I waited 45 minutes in line at Costco
for it I think it's gonna be probably my
best Tech Talk wait this is for a
tick-tock it's not for like what do you
not realize what do you mean is that my
phone can I take this back
take what back my phone no what hold on
a second everything's not always about
you I mean honestly it's been a really
kind of rough three weeks dealing with
my sister Justine I'm sure if you guys
follow her in the internet you know
she's been making all of this crazy
content on tick-tock well because we
won't be coming
[Music]
it's great and I'm happy for her but
it's actually been affecting my life and
I'm just really worried I really need my
phone hold on a second this would take
literally probably 30 seconds cuz it's
only 15 second video where's Tyler he
was supposed to be here 45 minutes ago
to help us know you told him he had to
stop to get something for tick tock oh
that's right I need ice cubes I've been
making videos with Justine for a little
over a year now and it's been great up
until recently do you need me I yes I
have to get this video to our friends I
don't know what you want me to do have
anybody dance with toilet paper yet so
when do I throw it in I just told you
never twenty-eight when you like money
this ever tony biglan
throw it when you feel it so what what
it does that so when it's that yes
okay you never told me that yeah I did I
always try to be supportive you know
I've been helping her make content for
the past ten years and I truly believe
that being supportive of your family
members and friends is important I just
don't know where to draw the line
am I being supportive or am I being an
enabler
[Applause]
actually a pretty good performance
it seems very authentic people love when
you post from the drafts one more I was
excited to work with Justine I was like
really thrilled about the opportunity
and she was sort of looking to elevate
her content a little bit and so I was
happy that we were gonna sort of take
things to a different level and now
that's all just completely gone had my
phone back
yes it's upstairs in the bathroom Oh
Tyler hello here late and this all
happened once before with an app called
vine and she just gets obsessed what
what are you what are you doing okay no
no one has done this tik-tok yet I
assure you what do you need cuz I ever
there work or do stuff like I need
phones we yeah like you're asking really
stupid questions
have you tried to confront her about it
or talk to her about it
yeah she doesn't care she said no I will
be famous on tik-tok right how does that
look I don't I can't see it I can't see
what you're doing this is what I'm doing
all right we're gonna start okay we're
gonna roll okay
[Music]
okay I think we really work on your
highness it seems like she's happy but
she has these outbursts that never used
to happen before hold on a second you
mess up the timing the only time she's
happy is when she gets a lot of views on
tick tock I mean honestly I am a little
scared we've been down this path before
and this time it's actually way worse I
think that she has a lot of insecurities
about tick tock dances I think she
really wants to do them but she just
kind of can't she tries to get me to
teach her these tick-tock dances as if I
know what she's talking about
she bought a $50,000 computer to edit
tic TOCs
it's gonna be great I really want the
audio to be the best that it can be so I
just need to sync it up here see you
these I think I'm almost done let me
give a little color grading here or
anything
I'm sorry what's wrong
see what movies I see what the movies
baby she wants to be tick-tock famous so
badly that she's even starting to buy
pop tops
[Music]
she hates crop tops
I can't just be making tic TOCs all the
time I can't but we can shoot look you
want to upgrade the gear like honest I
know you've wanted to start shooting
with red you don't need but yeah I just
bought a Mastro and I can't I just can't
keep doing it anymore and I'm not saying
I have anything against tick-tock I'm
just saying that it should be something
that's fun and I'm having fun I'm this
is a very calm and collected voice that
I am using okay okay what are you saying
we're just concerned about your
well-being and mental health it's fine
what I'm you just stop Jenna did you
know about this this is an ambush I feel
personally attacked it's fine if you
guys aren't on board it doesn't even
matter anymore because you know what
tick tock has a self timer and I can do
this alone Jenna Oh message me back
[Music]
well another thing about the phones is
she now carries six phones at a time and
I have to hold her backpack in her purse
a lot and that's heavy so that's just a
personal kind of upset about that